This is where multiprocessor comes in. If you're
implementing this RPC package on a shared memory multiprocessor,
then we can exploit multiprocessors that are are available
in the SMP. What we can do is, we
can preload the server domains. In a particular
processor. And what we mean by that is, if
we preload a server domain in a processor and,
and don't let anything else run on this processor.
This particular server is loaded on CPU 2.
We're not going to let any other thing disturb
what's going on in this CPU. What, what
that would mean is that the caches associated with
this CPU. Will be warm with the stuff
that this particular domain needs. So, in other
words, the server's address space is pre-loaded in
a particular processor. If you have multiple processors then
you can exploit the fact that you have
multiple processors in the SMP. So, if a client
comes along and wants to make an RPC call.
Then what we want to do is use the server
that has been preloaded in a particular CPU as
a recipient of this particular RPC call. So when
this client makes that call, that call is going to
be directed to the server that has been preloaded.
In a particular CPU and so the VP loaded in the CPU, the caches will be warm
and therefore we can avoid or reduce, mitigate
the impact on loss of locality. That I mention
to you that goes on when you go
from one protection domain to another protection domain. So
this is the happy state of the world where
what we have done is, we've first of all
eliminated kernel intervention in making the actual call and
return between the client and the server by providing
an argument stack in shared memory that is shared
in the address space of the client. And the address
space of the server. And this way, the client
can pass the actual arguments of the call to the
A-stack, and the server can retrieve it from the
A-stack without kernel intervention. And when the server is ready
to return the results back to the client, once again
it can do the same thing. Put it in the A-stack
so that it is available for the client. So, without any
kernel intervention, you can actually do the. Call and return, and
of course the mediation happens only in the fact that the
kernel has to validate the call. Every time the client makes
a call it has to validate that call. But the loss
of locality you can avoid by making sure that the server
domain is pre-loaded in one of the CPUs. And the other thing that the kernel can
do is look at the popularity of a
particular server. If a server is serving lots of
different clients than in a multiprocessor, then it
can potentially based on monitoring the site that we
may want to have multiple. CPUs very catered
to, the servers and that way you have several
different domains of the same server preloaded in several CPUs to, cater to the
needs of several simultaneous requests that may
be coming in for a particular service.